hello you are all looking so gorgeous
which is perfect because we're talking
about things beauty all show long
including a mega makeover this is the
before which is absolutely perfect and
gorgeous but hey you know what we all
live for an after so let's see how that
goes we'll check that out in a minute
but first Rossi Ross Matthews hello and
good morning hi everybody
[Applause]
I did a makeover on myself this morning
because I came to work and a truth be
told my hair was so dirty I was like we
just need to throw it up in a bun I'm
living that life where like I don't have
time to wash my hair yeah so this is
what happens I got an updo um but we
have someone very special joining us at
the desk she's a fashion and Beauty
junkie herself and we've seen her on
such shows as the handmaid's tale only
murders in the building Dave I mean
basically every hit show it's Christina
oh my God
we're talking about beauty this dress is
outrageous oh my God can you stand up
just I'm sorry if you're comfortable
doing that walk around
[Applause]
I love this arm shape yes you know it's
a tunic it is yes isn't it amazing you
guys beautiful
it's so funny too because our first
story actually has to do with a wedding
dress and your show only murders in the
building yeah so you wearing white is so
apropos will you take our first story
so glamor magazine gave us a sneak peek
of this Selena Gomez look from season
three of only murders in the building
Selena is serving beautiful bride with a
smoky cat eye contoured with bronzer and
a cherry lip Drew Ross what do you guys
think about her Glam oh I think if it's
your wedding date go all out yeah you
know what I mean like if you want to
wear a red lip it's your day do you she
looks Gorge what do you think I love
this look it was it sent the internet
Ablaze her and Steve Martin saying like
oh and then this happened pretending
that they got married I love you on only
murders in the building oh thank you
you play such a dual uh character in the
sense of like you frustrate people on
one level but then you're a new mom and
then you're a human being and then I'm
on your side and absolutely actor to
actor that's not easy to play not at all
so I'm the building manager I'm also
nine months pregnant in the show and so
you know I'm ready I'm ready for that
thing and um speaking of being ready
you're engaged to writer Alan yay and I
was wondering would you
[Applause]
any thoughts for your wedding dress
to the news
well no it was good to try an outfit on
before your wedding you know so you see
what you like I very much love like the
sporty feel of this and then I like a
little Rouge at the bottom but I was
thinking of going maybe silk and
something off the shoulder just very
classic so you know when you look at it
30 years down the line you're like
Timeless it's Timeless speaking of
modernizing something you know the
Cadbury bunny everybody yeah of course
the Cadbury bunny yeah well CNN reports
that the Cadbury bunny is actually a cat
this year so think of it as the cat
Berry bunny cute his name is crack look
at it and the eight-year-old one-eyed
rescue is the first cat to become the
Brand's official spokes Bunny and crash
will also star on the 2023 Cadbury
clucking bunny commercial and that takes
home five thousand dollars for himself
and then he gets to give five thousand
dollars to the shelter of his choice oh
my God why I know marketing came up with
this the genius honestly and I love that
it's a rescue I know because that's
what's so important and we have a
picture of you with your doggie actually
another rescue caliber
wait can I tell you she's 60 pounds
there but when I got her she was five
I thought she was gonna be a 10 pound
dog well I I think rescues are the best
um that's what I have and I just thank
you Cadbury whoever woke up in marketing
and was like we're gonna switch it to
crash and donate to shelters thank you
thank you
keep it here this should be a new
tradition exactly all right next Dell
magazine says clown core is in and
that's no joke a fashion designer Dior
Armani Prive even Chanel are showing
clown inspired Couture on the runway uh
and it's not just the runway remember
Harry Styles he rocked the Harlequin
print at the Grammys you know Drew and I
we actually got into clown core
yesterday on the show yeah that's right
that's
yeah are you down to clown okay do you
want my honest answer
honestly we always do honestly I don't
know that clown is my vibe but you know
I like people who celebrate their
fashion choices
um I think my character on my show Dave
likes a lot of color so that would work
yeah yeah sure yeah because it's hard to
wear all that and not look like a bozo
you know I do give me some Bozo anything
all right and finally the New York Post
reports on a new trend that's totally
bananas tick tockers are ditching Botox
injections in favor of rubbing banana
peels on their faces claiming they
prevent wrinkles now dermatologists say
there's no direct evidence that bananas
provide any skin benefits however the
fruit does contain antioxidants So
Christine I heard that maybe you want to
try it on your neck I do me too I'm
gonna follow you because your neck is
really where you notice the skin care my
so this is really soothing and I like it
yeah I don't I don't find it very
appealing oh wow look at that pun well
Christine I can't thank you enough for
coming to the desk because I'm telling
you you're in the best shows on TV
you're so talented and you're just
killing it out there in season three of
Dave is out now on FXX
[Applause]
for coming here and if you want to get
into clown core we got you a little a
little something too right there thank
you you're introducing me to so many new
things obviously I can't wait for season
three of only murders in the building
and just thank you so much for coming
here today thank you so much
[Applause]
audition on the Weekender we'll be right
back
there's a way to take a look from zero
to 100 is with lip vinyl which is all
the trend for spring it's somewhere
between a lipstick
and a lip gloss
[Music]
I'm done